SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to another episode of
our Google investing talks.
Today we have a very special
guest with us here today.
His name is Arnold Van Den Berg.
Arnold is a Chairman and CEO
of Century Capital Management,
which he founded in 1974.
Born in 1939,
Arnold Van Den Berg
survived the Holocaust
as one of Holland's
hidden Jewish children.
His parents both
survived Auschwitz,
and the family immigrated
to America when he was 10.
These struggles led him
to an extensive journey
and study of things like
investing, as well as things
like consciousness and
the subconscious mind,
which he believes is the key
to unlocking an individual's
potential.
There is a quote that is
often attributed to Einstein.
It goes something like this.
"Don't let your schooling
interfere with your education."
And Arnold, it seems,
he took it to heart.
He has no formal
college education.
It is through years of hard
self-study, dedication,
and more than 45 years
of industry experience
that he has gained
his market knowledge.
Prior to starting
Century Management,
he worked as a financial
advisor for Capital Securities
and John Hancock Insurance.
We are so delighted to
have him here in person
to share his
experiential wisdom,
not just about investing,
but also about life.
So without further ado,
ladies and gentlemen,
please join me in welcoming
Arnold Van Den Berg.
[APPLAUSE]
ARNOLD VAN DEN BERG: I will
start with where I was born.
I was born in Amsterdam, Holland
during the Nazi occupation
of Holland.
And if you look at
the Google Map there,
you can see where we lived.
We lived right down the
street from Anne Frank,
and some of you might
have heard her story.
Our family story was
very much like her.
My folks were hidden for
about two and a half years
in an attic, and they
developed one major problem.
The problem was that
when you're hiding
with two small children-- I
was two and a half years old,
my brother was five and a
half-- it was difficult to go
into hiding with them.
But there was a bigger
problem, and my parents
had to make a very
difficult choice.
If they kept the children with
them and they were caught,
they would be sent to Auschwitz,
which they eventually were.
But in Auschwitz, they didn't
keep women and children.
The minute a woman and children
would come, the first day,
they would gas them.
So it was a big risk.
If the children were
caught with the parents,
it usually meant the
end of the parents.
And the other
alternative on the choice
was to send us to the German
lines in an orphanage.
And the orphanage, in order
to get that orphanage,
you had to take a train.
And the problem with the train
is they check your passport.
We, being Jewish,
didn't have passports,
and so they had to
make a fake passport.
But the fake passport
wasn't very good,
so it was a big risk.
It was just like the
worst-case situation.
So anyway, my folks got
together with the underground,
the Dutch underground,
and they worked out
a plan where a 19-year-old girl
would take me on the train,
and then in front of her
would be an individual who
would try to keep the Nazi
officer who came on the train
to do the passports, keep him on
the train there, keep him busy
until the whistle blew
and then the officer had
to get off the train.
So we got on the train.
The officer came on.
The gentleman stood
up, kept him busy.
All of a sudden,
the whistle blew.
And as I spoke to this
woman after the war,
she says it was just the
most dramatic moment.
When the whistle blew, she
knew she was going to be OK.
So anyway, she got
me to the orphanage
where I was there from
about two and a half to six.
And then eventually,
my parents were
turned in by people in Holland
who did favors for the Germans,
and they got extra
food rations for that.
But the thing that
really got me is
the fact that this girl
risked her life to save me,
and somebody she
didn't even know.
By the way, that is
my family up there.
I'm in the middle.
And we are the
only survivors out
the 39 people that were
living before the war.
Anyway, the thing that as I
grew up I really struggled with
is, how could this young
girl risk her life for me?
She didn't even know me.
And how could her
whole family risk
their lives-- they were
hiding Jews and moving them
back and forth.
And the father would send his
19-year-old girl on a mission
that she could end up
in a concentration camp.
So I thought about
that for many years.
I tried to figure out, what
would motivate somebody
to do that?
And the more I thought about it,
I just didn't have an answer.
Well, as I got older, I
developed some problems.
I have a big anger problem.
I went through
years of depression.
And I finally went to
see a psychiatrist who
helped me a great deal.
And then as I was
thinking about it,
I thought, well,
I'm going to ask him
what he thinks about it.
And I thought a long
dissertation on this.
And he says, oh,
that's very simple.
I said, really?
He says, sure.
He said, it's all
about principles.
He says, these were people
who were deep Christians,
they had a big belief
in their religion,
and their principles were more
important than their life.
And he says, so
the way it works is
if you have principles that are
more important than your life,
you sacrifice your life.
If your life is more important
than your principles,
you sacrifice your principles.
And that is true
not only in life
where you have to sacrifice
your life, but also in business
where you have to
make choices that
sometimes cause sacrifices.
But anyway, I just want
to make this one point
about the principles that
really influenced my life.
Here on one side, you
had people who were
willing to risk their life.
And the other side, you had
people who would turn you
in for an extra food ration.
So just think.
Same people, same situation,
same circumstances.
One of them did this noble
thing that risked their life.
The other ones were
willing to turn
in for a matter of
an extra food ration.
So that really got me to
thinking how crucial in life
it was to have the
right principle,
to have something that really
was a compass that guided you.
And so I started
thinking about it.
And I was raised in
Judaism, so I started
studying the Jewish religion.
Studied all the different
ideas, and so forth.
But I wanted to also study the
other religion, and especially
Christianity.
Because these people
took such risks
that I wanted to see
what motivated them.
So I started studying
the religion.
The more I studied
the religions,
the more I got confused.
In one side, here the
Jews and the Christians
have been arguing
for 2,000 years.
And so all of a sudden,
I got into the debate.
I would go see a rabbi, talk
to ministers, Bible scholars,
Hebrew scholars.
Went through the whole thing.
And it really started to create
a problem with [INAUDIBLE].
And the conflict was,
here I was, raised Jewish.
My parents paid a
great price to be Jews.
And here, there were
things about Christianity,
there were principles
that I really liked.
And so one day, I was sitting
by myself, studying away.
And I thought, jeez.
How am I going to
reconcile this?
And all of a sudden, a voice
flashed through my mind.
It just-- not a voice.
A thought flashed
through my mind
and said, if you want
to seek the truth,
you have to go
wherever it leads you.
And I thought about
that for a moment,
and I thought, you
know, that's right.
And the minute I thought about
that, I just felt so relieved.
I completely felt free.
I just knew now that one
of my core principles
would be that irrespective
of what I was studying, what
I was looking for, I was
going to seek the truth,
and that was going to be
the guiding principle.
Completely relieved me.
This way, I went in and studied
all the different religions.
I learned a great
deal from all of them.
And all of these
different things
have led me to the
principles that I believe in.
Well, it didn't take long
to test those principles.
After I graduated out of high
school, I worked a few jobs,
and I got into the
insurance business.
And so I was very excited
about the insurance business.
I thought it was a
way to help people
and to create my own business.
Everything was going fine.
And then the more I
studied the business,
the more I saw that
certain products
that the company pushed
cost a lot of money,
had high commissions, but wasn't
necessarily the right product
for most people.
And the products that
I liked were very low
cost, gave the most
for the insurance,
also paid the least commission.
And so I figured, OK.
I believe in this thing.
I'm going to sell the
products that I believe in.
Well, after a few
years of selling that,
it's pretty hard to make money
at these low-cost products,
even though they were the best.
But I continue to do it because
I had developed the principles
that no matter
what it was, I was
going to do the right thing.
So one day after driving
all the way across town,
I come back to the office
about 9 o'clock at night.
Barely made enough money to
pay for my gas, let alone
the hours it took to drive
back and forth, and so forth.
And I come into the
office, and they
had sort of a honorary
thing where they honored
the top person of the month.
And the guy who got
the top of the month
was the guy who had the least
ethics in the whole company.
And so I thought to myself, how
could this great company honor
this guy when everybody
pretty kind of knows
the kind of situation he was in?
And I was just shocked by it.
I won't tell you what
I did to the picture.
But anyway, the
next day I walked
into the supervisor's
office and I said,
let me ask you a question.
You know the ethics
of this guy, right?
How could you make
him the top man?
He says well, Arnie, you've
never owned a business.
But I'm running a business,
and I've got overhead.
And so I need to
make my overhead.
Because otherwise, we
don't have a business,
and you don't have a job.
I just looked at him,
and I thought, well,
this is not the
right place for me.
I've got to leave this.
Well, that was
kind of a conflict
it created, because I'd
worked for three years,
and I'd built up these renewals,
which was part of our income.
And now I was going to
forfeit my renewals,
and I was also going
to forfeit my income.
And so basically, I was
going to be out a job.
But fortunately,
and in some ways
unfortunately, the
company had started
to go into mutual funds.
And I had started
studying mutual funds.
I was very excited about it.
And so I thought,
well, you know what?
I'm just going to
leave the company
and just make the mutual fund
the primary business, because I
was very excited about
what was going on.
So anyway, I thought about
that, struggled with that,
and the principles said, it's
obvious what you have to do.
So I started in the
mutual fund, and that
is the point where I said
fortunately and unfortunately.
Because at the time I left
the insurance business
and went into the mutual funds,
the market was six months away
from making an all-time high.
The market had been in a
bull market for 20 years.
It had just gone way up.
The enthusiasm was
just unbelievable.
And just to show you
what was going on,
this is an article out
of "Barron's" magazine
at the top of the market.
And they said, here's
all the top money
managers, the people I
used to go watch and sell
their mutual funds, and there
was not a bear among them.
In other words, the
enthusiasm was so high
that no money manager in
the country was bearish.
The inflation rate was down,
the interest rates were down.
But an important fundamental
that they seemed to overlook--
and I didn't have a clue
of what was going on--
and it turns out,
they didn't either,
because the market
eventually went down 45%,
the average stock went down
75%, and my mutual fund
started falling apart.
So this was the beginning of
my career in the stock market.
And so as the market
started going down and down,
and the funds kept
going down and down,
it was just very discouraging.
And I didn't have
the understanding
of how the market worked
or the evaluation of what
a company was worth, and so on.
And so it was just kind of like
the market kept going down,
because there was no
way I could evaluate it.
Anyway, I decided I
was going to study it
and to figure out
what was going on.
In the meantime, the market went
down for a total of six years.
Now there was one year that it
had bottomed in June of '70,
and it rallied for
about a year and a half.
And then it came crashing
down from '72 to '74.
So as the market was going
down and I was studying it,
I started to notice a pattern.
And the pattern was
that certain funds
did much better than others.
It's not that they went
up on a down market,
but they were going down,
but they weren't going down
as much, and they reacted
better when the market rallied.
And I could see a
noticeable difference.
So I started studying those
funds, and I thought to myself,
I'm going to find out
why it's different.
And so I called the
managers and I talked
to the other people involved.
And I finally concluded
that the people
who were following
the value investors
seemed to be doing better
in this extreme downturn.
So that got me interested.
I thought, well, maybe
that's the better philosophy.
So I talked to different
managers, I read the material.
And so all of a
sudden as you start
reading about value
investing, you
can't help but learn
about Benjamin Graham, who
was the father of
security analysis,
who basically developed
that value situation,
and whose prize student
was Warren Buffett.
So as I started
studying it, one day
I met a value investor who
had been very successful, very
knowledgeable about it.
And he said to me, you
know, Arnie-- we were having
dinner one night-- he says,
when you really break it down,
the secret of understanding
an individual stock
is to first of all figure
out what it's worth.
It's just like a
piece of real estate.
You call into brokers,
they do similar studies,
and you figure out your
square footage, the land,
and so forth.
And so you take
the fundamentals,
and you learn about the company.
And then the most
important thing,
and the only time
you get to do that,
is when the market is down.
Benjamin Graham described the
market as a manic depressive.
So when it's down, I bought
it in the manic state.
But when it gets depressed,
you get an opportunity
to buy it at a discount.
He said, basically,
you buy wholesale.
Well, that rang a bell with
me because all my life,
my mom was a tremendous
businesswoman.
She ran my dad's business
before the war, after the war,
and she was just amazing.
She always used to say, whenever
I buy something, Arnold,
you have to buy wholesale.
So I always remember.
It stuck in my mind.
So when this value
investor told me
that the secret to buying a
stock is to buy it wholesale
or at a discount, I thought, now
I have found the right thing.
This is for me.
So I thought to myself, one
day, I bought a sweater.
And I walk in to
my mom and said,
Mom, how do you like my sweater?
She says, oy, it's beautiful.
Did you buy it wholesale?
I said, Mom, you can't go into
a Bullock's and buy one sweater
and expect to get it wholesale.
She goes, nah.
She was not pleased
with the answer.
But I got the idea.
That was studying
the value investor
was the way I was going to go.
So now I had the
principles set up,
but now I needed the philosophy.
So I said, OK.
I'm going to do everything
I can to do this philosophy.
And I used to be an athlete.
And one of the things you
learn about athletics,
you've got to be
dedicated, focused.
You never skip practice.
So I set up a program to
learn value investing.
And I sat up-- I'm not
going out during the nights.
I'm not going to date.
I was single at the time.
I'm just going to
focus on learning
the value school of investing.
And I had all the books
lined up and all the pages
I had to read.
And every night, I
would chalk it off,
and I was making real progress.
Well, then I met this girl,
and we got along real well.
And she said to me, why don't
you come over Wednesday night?
I'll cook you a dinner
and we'll hang out.
And I said, oh, no.
I said, I've got to study.
And she said, really?
I didn't know you
were going to school.
And I said, no.
I'm not going to school.
I'm just studying.
She said, are you
studying for a test?
I said, no, I'm just studying
on my self-study program.
She looked at me
kind of funny and she
says, what are you doing,
studying to be a monk?
So the point I'm making is
that I was very focused on it.
Now what this young girl
didn't understand at the time
is that the most important thing
in achieving anything in life
is to be totally focused.
I learned that as
an athlete, but I
want to give you an
analogy which even
drives that point [INAUDIBLE].
My dad was explaining to me
what was going on in Auschwitz
in the concentration camp.
He said to me, you know the
most difficult thing that I ever
experienced in my
life, and especially
in the concentration
camp, is that when
I went on the death march.
And the death march
was a situation
where you had to go from
Auschwitz to another camp.
The camp was 60 kilometers,
which is about 20 miles.
He was about 85 pounds.
I'm 5'8", 160 pounds.
He was 5'7", and
he was 85 pounds.
So he was all skin and bones.
Everybody was.
So they started off
in the death march.
You get two slices
of bread, and you
march for 24 hours
in subzero weather.
The snow was halfway
up to your knees.
And your knees
started to buckle.
You would get so
tired you'd fall down.
They put a rifle
butt on your back,
or they whipped you till
you got up and got going.
Or if you didn't go,
they'd just shoot you.
So he said the key was
that he had to really focus
his mind to be able to
get through that kind
of a situation.
And he said, what I learned
by going through this death
march was just incredible,
how powerful the mind is.
And he said, you would never
know how powerful it was
until you were tested to do it.
I could never do this
without having to do it
when your life's on the line.
So he said, what I learned to
do is, he says, you take a step,
but you lock your knee
so you don't fall down,
because you're too tired.
You're going to fall down.
And he says, you had to
completely clear your mind.
He said, you couldn't think
about how tired you were.
You couldn't think about
how hungry you were.
You couldn't think
about how cold you were.
You couldn't think about
pain from the cold.
You could think
about nothing else.
Nothing should enter your
mind but to move that leg.
And he said, every
time I moved the leg,
I really didn't think
I could do another one.
But by focusing on it, I
just moved the leg again.
And throughout the 24
hours, I kept that focus.
And all of a sudden he says,
you realize you get a strength
that you don't even understand,
and you're able to keep going.
And I said, well, what
do you attribute it to?
He says, it has to be part
of the subconscious mind.
He says, I don't have
the answer to it.
But I can tell you this.
There is no way you
could ever do it
without that extreme focus.
So that's the key.
And so I wanted to point that
out to you, because that became
a focal part of my program.
And so as I started studying
the [INAUDIBLE] philosophy
and the value investing, as I
started learning these things,
I made that the complete focus.
That whatever you go
in, you focus that.
And of course, I
studied hypnosis,
which is a good way to
influence the subconscious
mind and any other
different program.
But I wanted to leave that
with you, because we all
have an energy and
a power within us
that we don't even realize.
And it's just truly,
truly extraordinary.
Anyway, I started my business.
And I'm going to show you the
difference in contrary opinion.
At the top of the
market when I got in,
everybody was wildly
bullish, and the market
was at 20 times earnings.
And now we are with the
market coming down six years,
and it was a real struggle
just to hang in there.
But I remembered the
lesson that I learned,
and I just knew that if I
had the right philosophy
and I kept going,
things will work out.
Well, I got so excited
about the value investing
that I realized when I studied
the multiples-- the multiples
at that time, you won't
believe it, were at about an
18, 19 multiple in the market.
The average stock was selling
at three to five times earnings,
and the big cap stocks were
about eight times earnings.
And they were bargain
6%, 7% dividends.
It was just incredible bargains.
And the more I studied
the value philosophy,
the more I realized
that we were truly
at an extraordinary
time in history
where the market had never been
that cheap, except going back
to the '29 depression.
So here we were,
30, 40 years later,
and this was the
cheapest market.
The only problem is I
didn't have many clients.
I wasn't making any
money, and each month, I'd
get deeper in debt.
But I had the faith that if this
was truly the historical time,
that eventually
things would change.
So then one day, I
come into the office.
And then I see this new article,
the cover of "BusinessWeek."
They had all the
sophisticated reasons
why the market was going to stay
down for the next few years.
Didn't have many
opportunities, and they called
it the "Death of Equities."
So here at the peak of
the market at 20 times,
everybody was bullish,
including the money managers.
Now we're at the
bottom of the market,
and they come out
with this article,
the "Death of Equities."
Everybody was bearish.
You couldn't talk to anybody
about stocks to save your life.
There was one person
who was bullish,
and that was Warren Buffett.
And he wrote an article or he
was interviewed in "Forbes"
in December of '74.
I'll never forget it.
And the only thing I remember
about the article that
stuck in my mind,
they were asking him,
what do you think
what's going on?
The inflation and all of this?
He says, look.
He said, if you're worried
about recession or depression
at these prices, I'm
not worried about it.
He says, this is the time
to invest and get rich.
And boy, that's what we did.
And six months later,
the market took off
into one of the biggest bull
markets that ever happened.
The Dow went from about 800
to 18,000, where it is today.
So that taught me a lot, going
through that market cycle.
If you ever want to really
learn value investing,
you learn it going
in a down market,
and you understand
what value is,
and how value eventually
might go down,
but it'll eventually come down.
And some of the things that
are not valued never come back.
So that's an important
part of the philosophy.
So as I was reflecting
over the time
that I'd been in business--
and it's been 48 years now--
I wanted to share
with you something
that would help you avoid
some of the mistakes
that we might have made
and some of the stocks
that didn't work out
as well, and so forth.
Well, as I looked over
the different ways,
there's many different
things that can happen.
But if I looked at one theme
that could help you a lot,
it's that debt is
one of the biggest
things against a business,
against an individual,
against countries and worldwide.
Matter of fact, it's the
biggest problem today.
So the problem was
that we would get
into stocks that were pretty
good companies at pretty
decent balance sheets.
They weren't over-leveraged
when we went in.
But as they were going
along, they either
made an acquisition
out of desperation
that didn't work out, or they
overpaid at the wrong time
when everybody was enthusiastic.
They developed products that
they didn't have any history
on, and they spent a
lot of money developing,
and then the products
didn't go on.
But most importantly, they
were people who didn't really
spend most of
their time thinking
about how to make the business
better, how to cut costs,
and how to keep going.
And then when things
started going down,
the mistakes that I
made was that we stayed
with those companies too long.
We got to know the management.
We got to believing in it.
I'm a big believer in people.
People is the thing
that change companies,
can change the world.
So when you get to
believing in companies
and then you see
them going along,
but you see them not doing
what they need to do,
then you need to cut
your losses and get out.
So it's important to
understand that debt
is something that really
takes the options away
from a company.
And if there's anything you
could [INAUDIBLE] there,
when you see them
going the wrong way.
Usually when companies
make acquisitions,
unless it's the kind of
company that consistently makes
acquisitions, and they
do it consistently well,
and they have a history
and an expertise to do it,
those companies
will do very well.
But if you see a company
that very rarely makes
an acquisition, all of a
sudden the business declines,
and then they hope-- they
throw a life saver out
to buy another company and
hope things will change,
and then they both start
going down, you get the idea.
So that is a very
serious problem,
not only in your personal
life, but also in companies.
And more importantly, let's take
a look at the United States,
because there's a
problem there also.
And I would say this.
Whenever people get
into financial trouble,
it's usually due to the
improper use of debt.
And when I started Century
Management, the only thing
I used, an American Express
credit card whenever
I needed to borrow some money.
First of all, I didn't
borrow any money.
Mostly at first, nobody
would have lent me
any money in their right mind.
But even as I had the
opportunity to borrow money,
I never did.
I either worked it down to where
the cost of revenues met cost,
or I'd just forego the debt.
I've never used debt as a
way to finance a company.
Anyway, if you look
at the United States,
as great as this
country is-- and I
wish I could talk more about
how wonderful this country is
and what a great future
it has, irrespective
of the temporary problems.
But one of the things
that concerns me
is that this country also
uses improper use of debt.
Now take a look at this chart.
It took over 200 years to
accumulate $7.9 trillion
of debt.
This is debt to GDP.
It's kind of like debt to sales.
In the last 10 years, we
went from $8 trillion to $19
trillion, an increase of 140%.
So obviously, we're
not using debt
in the proper way
because of the fact
that we've raised
this much debt,
and certainly haven't done
anything to cut costs.
Now the biggest problem
facing people with debt
is not only debt,
but the debt service.
So if you look at
this chart, you
can see that on the current
$19 trillion of debt,
we're paying $223
billion of debt service.
We have a budget deficit
of about $438 billion.
But the deficit on the
government's revenue,
if you take the deficit to
the revenue, it's about 13.5%.
Now look what happens
at the 3% line.
If interest rates were
to go up from 1% to 3%,
you would be at $616 billion.
That would give us
a deficit of $831.
And that would mean that
the amount of deficit
relative to the government's
income would be 30%.
Now there's two rules you
want to apply to a country.
First of all, it should not
have more than 80% debt to GDP,
and the deficit should not be
more than 30% of its income.
Because if it is, what the
central bankers of the world
and all people who
analyze countries realize,
that if you've got over
100% or over 80% debt to GDP
and you've got 30%
deficit on your income,
if you're spending 30%
more than you're making,
there's very little
chance you're
going to be able to
pay that debt back.
But countries have an option
that we don't, and that is they
can print money.
Well, what it means is that
if you meet those two ratios,
eventually, your cost of
your debt's going to go out.
Because people say, there's
no way out but to print money.
And in fact, that's what the
government has been doing.
Now just to show you what the
position of a government is in,
they basically have an
adjustable rate mortgage.
Because if they were really
doing the right thing right
now, they would sell 30-year
bonds so that they could
get the 2.5% interest tossed.
But instead, they're
rolling over short term,
because the short-term
costs are lower.
Well, it's just like have
a mortgage, adjustable rate
mortgage.
Let's say the mortgage
payment on $500,000 is 2.3%.
You've got $1,900
a month payment.
If you go to 5.3%, increase in
3%, the payment goes up 44%.
So what's going to happen
if interest rates go up,
you're going to develop
higher interest costs,
and that's going to
increase the deficit.
So that is one thing temporarily
that has to be resolved.
Fortunately, countries can
grow their way out of it
if we have the right
leadership and management,
but that's the
situation we are today,
and that is a very
trouble [INAUDIBLE].
If you look worldwide, you can
see the same thing going on.
Everybody's saying, well,
after the recession,
the world is deleveraging.
The world is not deleveraging.
Take a look at these statistics.
They have gone up every year.
And so what we've done is
we continue to pile up debt
on an individual basis,
on a company basis,
and countrywide and worldwide.
And that needs to be addressed.
Now let's take a look at where
we are today in the market.
I am showing you a chart
that shows the inflation
rate and the P/E multiple.
And this is a very important
thing to understand
and for you to watch for.
Right now, what is
the contrary opinion?
Everybody believes that
deflation is the biggest
problem in the world.
And it is.
But at the end of deflation
comes potential inflation.
And nobody's talking about it.
Nobody's thinking about it.
But you need to watch
it, because whatever you
don't expect usually happens.
On a contrary opinion basis,
the most contrary opinion
you can have is that you
can expect inflation.
Because the Fed has
been trying desperately
to create inflation.
They have not been
able to do it.
So if it does happen,
this is what's
going to happen to the market.
So what I am showing
you now-- and I'll
explain the value line index.
But I'm using a value
line index for this chart.
And you can see that we are
in the 1% to 2% inflation.
That is where we are today.
And the P/E is around
1770 to 18 times earnings.
Now here's the sweet spot.
The sweet spot in
inflation is 2% to 3%.
So you can see that you get
the highest multiple when
you've got 2% to 3% inflation.
Actually, 2.5%.
And the reason is, that
means the economy is strong,
everything is going well.
Interest rates are extremely low
and stock markets are way up.
So the ideal thing is if
the world comes together
and we get a little
more inflation, which
is a good thing, but
too much is disastrous,
then we could conceivably
go from the 18 to the 20,
and that would be the ultimate.
Now look what happens if
inflation comes and it goes
from the 3% to 4%, 5% and over.
If you go to the 4% to 5%, the
multiple drops from 20 to 14.
That's a 30% drop instantly.
And if you go to
5% or 6%, you're
going to go down to
a multiple of 10.
So this market
has the potential.
If inflation starts
to perk up and the Fed
doesn't act properly,
you could have a market
that goes down dramatically.
I am not predicting inflation.
I'm only suggesting
that you watch for it.
It could be years away.
I don't know.
But it's something to
be concerned about.
Now let me show you
something a little on history
that I thought you
would appreciate
knowing, because most people
don't realize how subtle it
is when inflation starts.
Now remember that chart I showed
you, "not a bear among them,"
everybody was bullish?
You know why they were bullish?
It was at the sweet spot.
We have 2.76% inflation, we
have reasonable interest rates,
we had a strong economy.
How could you not be bullish?
The only reason you
shouldn't have been bullish
is because the multiples
were way too high.
It's like Benjamin Graham said.
Price determines your return.
No matter how good a
company is, no matter
how good the situation is,
if the valuation is too high,
eventually something's
going to take it back.
And sure enough, this
is what took it down.
In January of '73,
you have a 2.76%.
One year later, just one
year later, the inflation
went from 2.76% to 4.93%.
It almost doubled in a year.
One more year later-- that's two
years-- and the interest rates
went from 2.76% to 11%.
And so you had a market that
went from 20 times earnings
down to seven,
eight, nine, and 10.
And that created this
disastrous bear market,
and that's what I went
through at the time.
So keep in mind
that inflation is
one of the biggest
enemies to stock prices,
because stock prices are
affected our interest rates.
And obviously, interest rates
are affected by inflation.
So let's look at the next chart
and this is my favorite one
indicator.
If you needed one
indicator to give you
the pulse of the market
to tell you where it is,
I would have understood
this indicator in 1968.
I would not have been
caught up in this market.
So here is the value line.
The reason I use the
value line in the S&P
is because the value line has
several features that I think
are really much better.
First of all, it's 1700
stocks instead of 500.
It gives you a
cross-section of the market,
which is much better than
just the S&P, which are mostly
big caps.
The second thing is that it's
a median P/E, not an average.
And so by a median
P/E, it sorts out
all the distortion that happens
when you have an average.
And the beauty
about this thing is
that if you look
over the 40 years
that I've been in the
business, or 48 years,
you can see that the
bottoms of the market,
irrespective of
how bad things get,
is about 10 times earnings
on the value line.
And it's only
happened four times.
You can see it in the chart.
The beauty about being
able to [INAUDIBLE] top,
the tops had never been
more than 20 times earnings,
and the tops have always
also been four times.
So you have a good
history of knowing
that when the market,
the value line
gets down to 12 times
earnings, it's about 25%
above the worst case, that's a
good time to be buying stocks.
And you know when it gets
to the 17 to 18 times,
it still has a little bit to go,
but you need a perfect world.
And if you don't
get a perfect world,
well, it could be going down.
Now one thing on the chart
that's really interesting,
you look at the left
side of the chart
and you can see the low point.
That was the time when the
interest rates went from 2.76%
to over 13%.
And so you can see that
those stocks in that-- that's
the only exception on
the inflation situation
is the fact that the stocks
went down to an average of 7.6%,
and they went as
low as 3% and 4%.
Now I remember in '74,
sitting there agonizing.
I had 25 to 30 stocks lined up.
They're all selling between
three and seven times earnings.
And I just couldn't
decide which one to buy.
This one's a little better,
but I don't-- this is a little
better.
This is a little--
back and forth.
All you had to do was throw a
dart and they all worked well.
So it's kind of like they say.
In a bull market--
in a bear market,
you don't want an analyst.
In a bill market,
you don't need one.
So when stocks are cheap--
[LAUGHTER]
--you really can buy
them at the right price.
OK.
And what I'd like to do
now is talk a little bit
about the two areas
that I think are
worth your while to look into.
I don't see too
many opportunities
in the stock market,
although there
are individual sectors
and individual stocks that
are reasonable.
They're not dirt cheap,
but they're reasonable.
But the areas that
are exciting me today
are the energy markets
and the gold markets.
And let's take energy first.
As you know, in energy
we had $140 oil price.
Everybody that
had a drilling rig
when out and drilled for oil.
We created this massive
surplus, and then the market
turned down.
And so we built
this huge surplus.
And so the price went down
from $140 down to $26 to $28.
Now if you read the
newspapers there,
all you would have had to
do is read the newspapers,
and you would have known that
you were in the value zone,
because that's the
contrary opinion.
All the experts were
saying that the oil
was going to go down to $20,
maybe even in the teens.
Who knows?
Whatever.
But the point about
it is if you looked
at the fundamentals
today, the oil,
the surplus is
kind of imbalanced.
The way they
measured a surplus is
by the number of
days of inventory.
At the high point when
you have a lot of surplus,
you can get 38
days of inventory.
And at the low
point, it's 25 to 26.
The average is about 32.
So 32 days of average
inventory is when
the market is in equilibrium.
Then the rest is
supply and demand.
OK.
The average is 32.
We are at 30.2.
So we are getting into
equilibrium where it's even.
It's even slightly
less than the average.
So that's the positive.
The other part is
that the production
is going down dramatically.
Throughout the world,
they have cut $1 trillion
of capital expenditures.
So you know, just
common sense says
that the decline is coming in.
So far, the demand,
surprisingly,
which is surprising everybody,
demand keeps going up.
And so the demand is going up,
the production is going down,
the drilling rigs,
the percentage
in drilling rigs in
operation are down 79%.
So you know that
production is going down.
And the projections are today
that the average inventory
could go down to 26 days
by the end of the year,
or let's call it nine months.
And that would mean that
that would be the lowest
inventory in 25 years.
The other thing
you want to look at
is that while you hear
about the productivity,
that they've been
able to cut the costs,
some people can produce oil
at $25 to $35 and so forth.
However, if you want to produce
95 million barrels a day,
which is what we
need, you're not
going to do it on
$50 or $60 oil.
The minimum that we
require is $60 to $65.
That's the marginal cost of oil.
In other words, most
companies are not
going to go out and drill
unless they can make $65.
Because some people
can do it, but there's
not enough of that cheap oil
to be able to meet the demand.
So we have to have a higher
price than $65 to $70.
And with the way it's going
under production costs,
I believe, it's my personal
opinion, by looking at this,
talking to the companies,
talking to all these people
who are very knowledgeable,
there is the possibility
that if they don't start
the production soon,
that one day we might even
have a temporary spike in oil.
So the opportunities
in oil are there.
The valuations are still good.
And there's opportunities
in the stocks and the bonds,
and that would be something I
would direct your attention in.
The next thing I would like to
do is cover the gold market.
Now let me say this.
I am not a gold buyer.
I have only owned gold
three times in 48 years.
I am a value investor.
And when a market goes down
for five straight years,
and it goes down 85%, which is
what happened to this market,
you are in market evaluations
that only happened 2% or 3%
of the time.
So buying into the gold
market at the turn of the year
was like buying
into stocks in 1974.
The market had gone down
five years, 85% down.
Any time a market
goes down 65%, you
want to dust it off
and start looking.
But when you've got 85% decline,
that's pretty extraordinary.
But here is a very
important statistic,
and that is there
are $294 trillion
worth of assets, cash stocks
and bonds, in the world.
That's all the
assets in the world,
not counting real estate.
All the gold in the world
is only $7 trillion,
and half of that is in
jewelry and technology.
So you only have
about $3.5 trillion
that is tradeable in gold,
and it's probably even less.
Now if 1% of the people
into the $294 trillion
decide to move 1% of
their assets into gold,
that would be $2.9 trillion.
That 1% would be enough to
absorb all the gold that's
ever been mined in the world,
and that is extraordinary.
And that is an
unusual opportunity.
The market has come
up quite a bit,
so I've cautioned diving in.
It's worth looking into.
Now let me just take a couple
of moments [INAUDIBLE].
Well, what's going to
make people buy gold?
It's been around
for 5,000 years.
Why would they buy any more?
Well, first of all,
there's $10 trillion
in negative interest
rates today.
We've never had that in
the history of the world,
negative interest rates.
So there's $10 trillion.
There's $12 trillion
dollars that
has been printed
throughout the world.
That's another potential.
We've got the enormous
worldwide debt.
And more importantly, we've
got worldwide uncertainty.
So I really believe that
over the next few years,
there's going to be a tremendous
flow into these gold markets.
And let me just say one
thing, which most people don't
realize, and I hear everybody
who's critical of gold saying.
Whenever we cut the ties
to gold in August of 1971--
I'll never forget that day.
I didn't think I could ever
believe that the United
States would cut its link
with gold and the dollar,
the dollar was always supreme.
So we became a fiat currency.
If you would have bought gold,
which we did at that time,
the average return is
7.96% over 44 years.
If you bought it 20 years ago,
the average return is 6.48%.
And if you bought
it 10 years ago,
the average return is about 8%.
If you bought it at the top of
the market in 2011 till now,
you would have lost 2.5%.
The point I'm making, over
any 10 or 20-year period,
you're going to make
6% to 9% on your money,
irrespective of whether
it pays dividends.
And I know you could do better,
but you could also do worse.
In this type of environment, I
see it's a great opportunity.
It's something you
should look into.
Don't dive into it right away,
because it had a big run.
But energy and
gold are something
that are worthwhile
as a value investor
that you want to look into.
I want to summarize this
program with these things,
to summarize the things that I
learned through my experience.
First of all, always
seek the truth.
Number two, develop your
own set of principles.
Not the ones you
were taught, not
the one part of your
religion, but the ones
that you make and own
yourself, and the ones you're
willing to make a sacrifice for.
Be totally focused on everything
you do so you can not only
harness your intelligence,
but the greater intelligence
of your subconscious mind.
It only comes through focusing.
And by practicing the principle
and following the philosophy
and sticking with it, you
develop tremendous faith
and courage.
And that's the kind
of thing you need
to go through any difficult
time that you might
have to go through your life.
And finally, and the most
important one, never give up.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you
so much, Arnold.
This was very inspirational, and
I expected nothing different.
So folks, we are open
for questions now.
And just a small announcement.
After the talk, if somebody
wants the books autographed
by you, would that be OK?
ARNOLD VAN DEN BERG: Oh, sure.
SPEAKER: So there will
be some books there,
and Arnold will be
here to autograph them.
ARNOLD VAN DEN BERG: And if
I could just take a second
to explain the book.
One of my hobbies is
collecting quotations.
You know, Socrates
said, "employ your time"
in reading great
people's lives so you
can learn in a very simple
way what it took them
all their life to do.
And the best way I've found
to do that is to quote.
Sometimes in a quote, you
can capture what a person
took their whole life to learn.
Incredible wisdom through that.
And so I have about 5,000
quotes on my computer,
and I log them by subjects.
So whenever I'm
studying a subject,
I have the chance to read what
all the great people thought
about it.
So I made a little
quote book on that,
and I'd like to
share that with you.
The second book is
"Poverty to Power."
It's one of the most
extraordinary books
that I have read over my career.
I've been reading it
for over 30 years.
And when I went
to the publisher,
say, I wanted to
buy a big volume
because I wanted to give
them out to friends, family,
and clients.
He said, oh, we only
publish about 25 books.
So I thought, 25 books.
A book this great?
Anyway, the reason I
recommend this book
is because this
gentleman, James Allen,
is one person that has spent
his whole life seeking truth.
And he's searched through
all the different cultures,
religions.
You can't imagine.
And I have never had a
problem where I couldn't
find the answer in that book.
So I hope you'll use that
as a source in your life.
SPEAKER: Thank you, Arnold.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
It was really great
hearing you talk.
So as a value
investor, what do you
do when you don't see an
opportunity in the market?
What's your stance on cash?
ARNOLD VAN DEN BERG:
As a value investor,
what do you do when you
don't have any options?
Over the 40 years or so
that Century Management's
been in business, our average
cash position was 20%.
I always felt that
holding back cash,
even when there's
great opportunities,
there's always
opportunities to go along.
So we always had a higher cash
position than most people.
But in a time when
there are great values,
we have a little less cash.
Today, I feel one of the
best cash items is gold.
And so we don't
have as much cash,
but we do have a lot
more in the gold market.
So the answer is cash.
Even if cash doesn't
make any money,
it's better than losing money.
So you have to be patient.
And that's one of the principles
you learn is patient pays off.
One thing I can tell you of
being 48 years in the business,
you will always find
values if you're patient.
You might have to wait
a year and a half.
You might have to
wait two years.
But my God, what I went
through writing this thing down
for six years, I wouldn't wish
that on the worst human being.
That's a terrible thing to do
to come to the office every day
and just get beat up.
It's just like a torture.
So if you're not sure, if you
don't have a great opportunity,
it's better to take no
interest than it looks.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious about Apple.
It's, like, the world's
biggest company.
The P/E is probably
at, like, 10.
[INAUDIBLE] 7 P/E. And
meanwhile, all the other tech
companies are way
higher, like Microsoft.
SPEAKER: So the
question is about Apple.
It's a low P/E, about 10.
And they have a lot of cash
on their balance sheet.
So if you take the cash out,
it's even lower P/E in effect.
How do you think about
that, because all other tech
companies are selling at
more expensive prices?
ARNOLD VAN DEN BERG: Well,
I think by all criteria,
you would have a great value.
The question that
I have-- and I'm
sorry that I can't give you a
definitive answer, because we
don't follow it.
We're not in it.
But the thing is,
from all standpoints,
just from a cursory standpoint,
you're right about the cash.
If you took it on,
it'd be cheaper.
They've got all
this opportunity,
they've got a lot of
money in the bank.
But my question
is, what are they
going to do for the future?
That's the most important thing.
And I'm not qualified to
answer that, because I'm not
a technical person.
But if I was looking
at the company,
and we've looked at
it back and forth,
the thing that I have
a big question mark
is, what are they going
to do into the future?
Because you can have a
low P/E. As long as you
have less than 10
times cash flow,
you get a 10% cash flow return.
And so you could keep this
even if it didn't go up.
If the price didn't go up,
the value keeps going up,
and it pushes the price up.
So I wouldn't fault
anybody for saying this
is an extraordinary bargain.
But the question I
have, and you would
be able to answer it better than
I do, is what is the future?
And I remember one of
my analysts came to me
and he says, Arnold, we
ought to look at Apple.
And it was the highest
capitalization in the market.
And I said, you
know, Dale, I said,
it's been my experience
when a company gets
to be the biggest capitalization
in the history of the market,
if you look at the
next five to 10 years,
the performance
isn't all that great.
Now that's not a
judgment on the company.
But when it's so big, bigger
than anything around, what
did they have to do to create
that growth to keep it going?
So it's a very good question.
I wish I could give
you the answer.
If I could, I'd probably buy it.
SPEAKER: So unfortunately,
we are out of time.
But I hope there will
be time to continue
this conversation outside.
ARNOLD VAN DEN BERG: Oh, sure.
SPEAKER: So thank you, everyone.